[Music]
new issue of Vanity Fair magazine hit
the stands yesterday and it features an
interview with disgraced fashion
designer John Galliano the article says
it's Galliano's first ever sober
interview now you may remember that
Galliano got in trouble a while back
from making drunken anti-semitic remarks
and just refresh her memory here's a
photo of Galliano and here's another
photo of Galliano and yet another photo
of Galliano well we wanted to talk to
John Galliano about his Vanity Fair
interview he says he's too busy we were
however able to get in touch with John
Galliano's brother Joe Galliano he's
with us now via satellite from Paris
let's see if we get the connection right
there we go please welcome Joe
good evening Joe then Swami okay yes now
now Joe
your brother's interview in Vanity Fair
suggests that he's finally turned his
life around is that right yeah he's a
new man okay so what you're saying then
is your brother's no longer the raging
drunk who says that he loves Hitler is
that right of course not now he's the
contract teetotaler who's indifferent to
him indifferent
so is he worried that his new sobriety
will affect his creativity is he his
genius doesn't come from chemicals it
comes from the furnishing dog okay all
right so what can we expect from
Galliano in the next season just curious
what we can look forward to
[Applause]
brilliance really well maybe you could
be a little more specific than just
saying brilliance what do you say more
specific embrace my vagueness all right
well anyway I wish your brother luck on
his road to recovery although you have
to admit it may be quite a while before
he's forgiven forgiven by the Jewish
community we're working on it isn't that
right little moisture
[Applause]
that's great all right well
[Applause]